euh on va parler de d'elfelfin jubilard
qui reste introuvable euh son mari
cédric est le seul et unique suspect il
attend son procès qui aura lieu en 2025
en attendant des éléments et témoignag
refont encore surface on va revenir sur
ce mystérieux témoin affirmant que le
corps de Delphine se trouve sous une
dalle de béton d'une maison en
construction et on aura des infos grâce
à un des amis de Cédric jubilard cyil
hermainquer qui vient souvent nous voir
et bien sûr Michel Marie et puis on va
parler de l'affaire euh l'affaire Lina
excusez-moi l'affaire Lina et Lina vous
allez voir il y a des rebondissements
incroyables euh sur cette affaire g ver
avec Michel qui a des infos fou regardez
déjà le petit Réap sur jupilard c'est
parti merci
merci en 2020 les Français découvraient
l'affaire Delphine jubilar le mari de
Delphine jubilar disparu en décembre
dernier a été mis en examen pour le
meurtre de sa femme si l'enquête pour
tenter de retrouver la jeune femme a été
clôturée elle pourrait bien connaître
des rebondissements avec les témoignages
de nouveaux témoins l'un d'eux qui
évoque la disparition d'une pelleteuse
d'une maison en construction indique que
son corps pourrait se trouver sous une
dalle de alors disparition d'une pteuse
dalle de béton suspecte de nouvelles
pistes pour enfin retrouver le corps de
Delphine jubilard ont fait le point ce
soir dans
TPMP merci Michel Marie je parle de toi
merci Michel et merci c d'être avec nous
également puisqu'on va revenir sur
l'affaire jubil c'est quoi cette
histoire de maison en construction et de
dalle en béton alors cette affaire n'en
finit pas de rebondir comme vous pouvez
le
constater à un moment qui est qui tombe
mal puisqu'il y a plus d'instruction que
le dossier est
clôturé et donc il y a une procédure en
cours pour un supplément d'information
et au moment où il y a cette cette
espèce de vide juridique au mois de
décembre dernier un homme se présente à
la gendarmerie pour dire qu'il avait des
révélations à faire qu'il savait où se
trouvait le corps de Delphine
juilard et là il explique
que il a repéré une maison à proximité
de de la maison à CNAC
lesmine que c'était une maison en
construction et que sur ce chantier un
bulldoer enfin une pelleteuse avait
disparu à une date qui était très proche
de la disparition de Delphine le
problème c'est que les gendarmes ont pu
juste l'entendre comme ça mais ne
peuvent pas poursuivre les
investigations parce qu'il y a plus de
juges parce que il y a le dossier est
clôturé il était renvoyé devant la Cour
d'Assise voilà et il y a un autre un
autre élément mais je pense qu'on en
parlera un petit peu plus tard c'est les
les écoutes téléphoniques non on va en
parler maintenant on pe en parler
maintenant en réalité il y a il y a
quatre personnes qui seraient intérêt
que les gendarmes auraient intérêt à
entendre il y a donc cet individu qui se
présente pour euh cette histoire de
pelleteuse et puis également on a une
écoute
téléphonique d'un détenu qui s'appelle
Salem il se trouve que ce détenu se
trouvait dans la même prison
que que Cédric jubilard
et ce que les gens ce que ce qu'on
intercepte en le dialogue qu'on
intercepte c'est la mère et ce détenu la
mère dit tiens ça y est jubilard est
renvoyé devant la Cour d'Assise et le
détenu Salem dit pourtant il y a pas de
preuve et puis il énumère trois prénoms
je m rappelle plus de si Sébastien et
Mathieu qui il dit de toute façon ils ne
connaissent pas il en parlant des
gendarmes ils ne connaissent pas Mathieu
Sofiane et Sébastien et la mère dit ha
s'il savait elle a fait comme ça la mère
elle a fait a j'en ai rajouté un petit
peu mais en gros elle a dit a s'il
savait s'il savait ah s'il savait alors
évidemment cette cet enregistrement
était communiqué aux enquêteurs lesquels
enquêteurs ont le même problème que que
pour l'histoire de la peteuse il y a
plus de il y a plus de cadre juridique
qui permettent de travailler d'où la
demande du parquet de de Toulouse de de
faire un supplément d'information pour
entendre tout ce petit monde exactement
alors là il y a un témoignage important
celui de Cyril et Marder qui est proche
de Cédric jubidard et de sa dernière
compagne donc vous avez parlé à
Séverine que vous a dit céverine sur sa
relation avec CÉC jubilard c'est la
dernière compagne de Cédric jubilard
elle vous a dit quoi alors céverine je
l'ai connu suite à mon passage ici sur
l'émission qu'on avait fait sur Cédric
jubilard où j'ai été venu apporter
quelques quelques éléments derère vous a
contaé et juste après j'étais en train
de rentrer chez moi et je reçois un
message sur Messenger qui me dit je suis
la compagne de Cédric jubilard et dans
la foulée au début je lui dis tu es sûr
elle m'envoie une photo elle est avec
lui et là je dis bon il y a plus de
doute et et donc je l'appelle et là
s'enit une longue conversation pendant
tout mon trajet de retour et de fil en
aiguille on a on a sympathisé et
maintenant ça fait 2 ans quasiment que
je suis régulièrement en lien avec elle
c'est incroyable et euh et où tous les
deux on on suit cette affaire parce que
l'affaire jubilar faut savoir que c'est
un petit peu un rouleau compresseur
quand vous êtes proche de jubilard ou
quand vous commencez à avoir l'audace de
dire que peut-être il n'est pas l'auteur
du du crime de sa femme tout le monde
vous tombe dessus j'ai perdu énormément
d'amis qui m'ont dit mais attends tu as
été défendre un criminel mais comment tu
peux faire ça
au niveau professionnel c'est très très
lourd à
porter au niveau médiatique il faut
savoir que le scret de l'instruction n'a
jamais été respecté dans cette affaire
là moi j'ai des journalistes dont un du
Parisien qui est venu me sortir des
éléments de ma déposition chez les
gendarmes quand je les ai aidé à faire
le profil de Cédric jubilard ces mêmes
gendarmes qui me disaient d'ailleurs
après mon passage ici c'est comme ça
qu'ils m'ont
découvert quand on cherche du côté des
amis de Delphine pour un profil on en a
plein par contre quand on regarde côté
Cédric jubilard à part vous pour
l'instant on a pas grand monde et donc
Séverine j'ai vu en l'espace de de ces
deux années ben je l'ai vu sombrer je
l'ai vu vraiment touché par ce par cette
affaire c'est-à-dire tous les
problématiques qu'elle a pu avoir au
niveau du travail elle n'a plus de
travail et elle a beaucoup de difficulté
à en avoir un nouveau toutes les
problématiques qu'elle a eu par rapport
à son fils qui a été mis en cause aussi
dans l'histoire toutes les
problématiques qu'elle a eu avec la
famille de Cédric notamment avec sa mère
qui qui lui a repris une voiture dont il
lui avait laissé la la jouissance
euh voiture qui se l'a dit en passant
selon elle n'a jamais été expertisée par
la gendarmerie il s'agissait d'une 307
break euh ça c'est quelque chose a donné
la voiture euh en fait il lui a donné en
jouissance la voiture il a fait une
lettre depuis la prison qu'il a donné à
sa SPIP ça conseillère pénitenti station
de pration dans lequel il lui dit qu'il
laisse la jouissance de la maison et de
la voiture à Séverine et euh au-delà de
tout ça euh un jour Séverine euh à la
mère de de Cédric jubilard qui qui vient
chez elle avec des clés qu'elle sort de
je ne sais où et qui prend la voiture et
qui s'en va avec et là Sverine appelle
les gendarmes en disant mais comment
elle peut faire ça il m'a laissé la
jouissance puis en plus les papiers non
l'ancien propriétaire n'ont même pas été
fait euh donc où est-ce qu'on en est
comment on peut faire et euh et donc bon
on lui dit ben non mais c'est comme ça
et voilà et là bon Séverine jette
l'épongche je dis tant pis tant pis pour
la voiture la maison elle avait rendu
les clés mais pendant longtemps elle
avait accès à la maison même pendant
toute toute l'instruction euh elle a
rendu lesclés à gendarmerie en disant
moi je ne veux plus d'histoire avec ça
l'épisode qu'elle a eu avec Marco qu'on
a eu sur le plateau il y a peu de temps
l'avait énormément traumatisé parce que
elle elle s'est dit je me suis retrouvé
avec quand même un criminel à côté de
moi quelqu'un que que par bonté par
bêtisse j'ai voulu aider pour pouvoir
trouver la vérité pour retrouver le
corps de Delphine parce qu'elle
s'inquiète énormément de de ce qu'il a
pu devenir et au final elle s'est
retrouvé en garde à vue pour celle de
cadavre dont à la fin elle est ressorti
bien sûr avec un non lieu et elle a été
suspectée de de de complicité Séverine
oui tout à fait de savoir où est le
corps voilà tout à fait alors est-ce
qu'elle sait où alors elle ne sait
absolument pas où est le corps elle a
aussi subi une une vous avez vu les
lettres qui se sont envoyées entre
Séverine et
C sûr en fait au fur et à mesure de sa
de sa relation avec et moi de la
relation que j'ai eu avec elle j'ai été
au courant en temps réel un peu de ce
qui se passait donc j'ai eu accès bah au
papier où il dit à ça c'est PIP qui
laisse en jouissance la la la maison euh
les lettres qu'il a pu lui écrire qui
sont les lettres de de d'un homme plein
d'amour pour sa pour sa compagne
euh d'information sur un peu compliqué
si ce n'est la la solitude qu'il a si
vous voulez je peux vous lire un extrait
d'une des
lettres un extrait d'une des lettres de
de Cédric jubilard si vous voulez voir
son écriture je je peux vous montrer à
quoi ça grapholog à quoi ça
ressemblem cont vois toutes les photos
là il y a du cul non je
rigole de sex c'est bon je rieny
allez-yzy donc euh c'est c'est une
lettre donc estampillé Cédric jubilard
avec son son numéro d'écrou bien
évidemment
et qui qui qu'il avait envoyé alors
celle-ci elle date de avril mai 2022 le
temps vous allez nous lire une lettre
qui envoyé Cédric jubilard sa dernière
compagne et donc où il écrit coucou mon
ange comment te dire pour moi cela fait
3 mois que je n'ai reçu aucun courrier
de ta part et je croyais que c'était moi
qui avais fait quelque chose de mal et
que tu ne voulais plus correspondre
voilà je ne t'envoyais plus de cour ne
sevait rien de ta part je croyais que tu
avais tiré un trait sur notre histoire à
la suite de ta garde à vue ah ouais euh
hop là attendez excusez-moi j'ai mon
téléphone qui fait des cennes hop
là il est àou ce téléphone oui tout à
fait mais il est nouveau alors du coup
j'ai encore un peu de mal à m'adapter à
ça a Michel Marie me regarde cro qu'il a
sorti une c'est le téléphone de
juil sorti la VAN du siècle alors
allez-y allez-y comend donc je croyais
que tu avais un trait sur notre histoire
à la suite de ta garde à vue et que tu
étais passé à autre chose
et si tu me renvoies un courrier par
semaine comme avant faisant en sorte de
t'écrire l'écriture est un peu compliqué
comment au niveau de la
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
lectureyz-y allez-y allez je continue
euh aussi voilà raison c'est le silence
de ma
part donc on reprend j'ai reçu juste de
je sais pas quoi pour le mois de mars je
te DIRIS dans un prochain C de ta part
il y a quelque chose d'intéressant dans
cette lettre oui que quelques personnes
le soutiennent dehors ah c'est ça il
parle de vous ah ça c'est pas mal quand
même on y
arrive donc je reviens sur mon courrier
désolé il s'est remis
voilà et donc mais ne sont pas
nombreuses heureusement donc il a
quelques vrais amis fidèles comme Cyril
moi-même
euh et de du coup il clôture sa lettre
par je t'aime toujours comme un fou euh
je t'embrasse tendrement mon cœur tu me
manques et il fait un petit cœur à la
fin voilà d'accord donc euh VO des élés
sont toujours ensemble ou pas ils sont
toujours ensemble ça alors justement
c'est là que j'all venir c'est aussi la
tristesse de cette histoire c'est que
Séverine avoir ce type de relation ce
nétait plus possible pour elle parce
qu'il y avait un trop de conséquences
sur sa vie sociale et sur sur sa vie de
tous les jours euh elle a donc pris du
prix du recul et aujourd'hui oui on
pourrait dire tirer un trait sur ça elle
veut passer à autre chose mais c'est
très très compliqué pour elle et elle me
rappelé avant que je je n'arrive ici que
elle avait été aussi ben une maman de
cœur pour les les deux enfants jubilards
ou donc pour pour Louis Elia et que le
petit Louis lui disait juste avant que
son père ne ne soit mis en garde à vue
et qu'après il soit incarcéré euh est-ce
que tu peux remplacer maman et qu'elle
lui disait non mon cœur maman je ne
pourrais jamais la remplacer mais on va
la retrouver ne t'inquiète pas alors
c'est là c'est vrai que le témoignage
est très fort de cyil on a rigolé tout à
l'heure mais à Cyril juste il paraît il
lui aurait dit que Delphin avait
plusieurs amants est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler de ça parce que c'est quand
même important alors il faut savoir que
c'est le nouveau détective je crois qu'
avait sorti
ça il a l'air comme ça mais c'est pas
l'ancien c'est nouau mais on avait
vu ça van ce soir
on a on avait vu que effectivement elle
était sur plusieurs applications de de
rencontrre notamment gliden et euh moi
c'est un peu ce qui me dérange aussi
dans cette affaire c'est que on nous a
vendu ça on va on va Rapp pour les
femmes infidèles pour les femmes
adultères et euh et donc on dit souvent
elle avait l'amant de montauan qu'elle
voulait refaire sa vie un peu comme une
princesse qui avait retrouvé l'amour
après avoir un mari viol Montan c'est ça
mais en réalité elle avait plusieurs euh
amants plusieurs relations ça c'est
intéressant et et en fait tout tout cela
ça a été creusé petit à petit au fur à
mesure que l'instruction s'est faite
d'ailleurs de tout façon il y a eu des
fuites au niveau des journalistes comme
sur tout le reste comme d'habitude mais
comme ce n'était pas vendeur c'est pas
quelque chose qui a été mis trop en
avant c'est resté quand même assez à la
marge
et c'est surtout très diffamatoire alors
est-ce que c'est diffamatoire ah bah oui
aller savoir parce que ah non il y a pas
aller savoir c'est diffamatoire quand on
dit d'une femme surtout qui est
victimeelle a plusieurs amants alors en
fait on n sait rien euh je pense que
c'est diffamatoire et je suis pas que on
partira du principe sans tomber dans la
diffamation qu'elle avait donc un compte
Glidden que sur celui-ci elle avait fait
plusieurs rencontres qu'il y avait le
fameux ami David qui était à 3h30 de là
et qui avait été découragé par la
distance pour pour venir on verra la
façon dont en parler laament quand il
dit moi avec Delphine c'était sushi
champagne hôtel elle me coûtait cher
mais j' un bon retour sur investissement
bon j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir une
grande histoire d'amour naisscante vous
m'excuserez néanmoins c'est votre avis
je ne veux pas tomber dans la
diffamation moi je vous dis ce que ce
que j'ai
pu voir ou ou avoir comme retour de la
part de
Séverine je ne suis pas dans des
accusations portées ensuite c'est je
rappelle quand même que Delphine
aujourd'hui elle est victime sûrement
probablement mais nous n'avons toujours
pas de corps nousavons toujours pas de
scène de crime toujours pas d'armes du
crime on est quand même dans dans une
situation qui est vide donc si moi vous
me dites que affirme est imparfait quand
on affirme que Delphine est morte ou qu'
ou qu'elle a été victime de son mari on
est là aussi dans quelque chose de
totalement diffamatoire donc je pense il
faut toute proportion garder et voyez
par exemple les juges d'instruction
lorsqu'il renvoi aux assises et qui
disent qu'on a un ensemble d'éléments
qui disent que effectivement il est
l'auteur du crime de sa femme là aussi
c'est quand même assez assez violent et
c'est pour ça que ces avocats ont fait
appel de ça et au niveau déontologique
les magistrats ont quand même des choses
à revoir Michel vous vouez réagir parce
queah non j'ai écoute j'écoute ce
monsieur respectueusement
euh sur pour j'ai pas envie de m'étaler
sur la la vie privée d'une femme qui a
disparu qui est probablement morte il y
a plein d'éléments dans le dossier vous
le savez comme moi qui tend à penser que
Cédric
jubilard n'est pas tout à fait pour rien
dans la disparition de sa femme euh il
était renvoyé quand même devant la Cour
d'Assise c'estàd qu'il y a quand même
deux juges d'instruction et un procureur
de la République qui ont considéré qu'il
avait les charges suffisantes pour le
renvoyerant la cour d'assise il n en a
surtout aucune moi je vous en prie mais
jugesinruction le procureur moi j'ai une
question poser cy est-ce que Séverine
pense que céric jubilard est
coupable moi à chaque fois que moi à
chaque fois déjà des doutes moi à chaque
fois que je l'ai eu
elle ne le pensait pas elle a douté par
la suite et aujourd'hui elle ne veut
plus avoir d'avis aujourd'hui elle veut
que ça ça soit loin d'elle parce que
elle n'a pas envie de se retrouver à
nouveau à passer sous ce rouleau
compresseur médiatique où on va dire la
vie de Séverine qui pense que machin
ceci cel vous êtes policier non euh oui
je l'étais jusqu'à il y a peu euh est-ce
que vous avez vous alors moi j'aimais
avoir votre avis à vous est-ce que vous
vous avez le
sentiment exactement que Cédric jubilard
peut être
innocent moi personnellement c'est ce
que j'étais venu dire sur ce plate quand
j'étais passé il y a 2 ans c'est ce que
je dis encore aujourd'hui c'est ce que
je maintiendrai tant qu'on a'ura pas
d'éléments probants parce que
aujourd'hui à part l'intime Convenction
des juges nous n'avons strictement rien
dans ce dossier on a des soi-disant
faisceau d'indice grave et concordant et
surtout pourquoi on lui a refusé sa
liberté ou sa mise sous bracelé pendant
toute toute l'instruction alors qu'il
aurit très bien pu l'avoir non pas parce
qu'il y avait des éléments comme souvent
ça a été sous-entendu hein simplement
parce que il y avait un risque de
trouble à l'ordre public à cause du
tapage médiatique qu' avait eu et je
vous vois lever les yeux au ciel mais je
vous garantis que que les propos de c
bien sûengage lui a des éléments qui son
quand
même on va Rapp les
élé il y a plein d'éléments àablant
quand
mêmeich vas-y don
lesl prendre à rebour il y a aucune
autre piste qui tient encore la route
toutes les autres pistes ont été
refermées de la vie de deux juges
d'instruction ça fait des milliers de
page pour eux cédric jubilard est le
meurtrier vous répondez pas quel est l'é
est l'élément demande un élément mais
tous les éléments c'est que il y a que
lui qui était là dans la maison c'est
pas un élément
ça Michel va donner mich non mais il y a
il y a tout un faisceau
de gra concordant qu faauice grav
concordant vous êtes policier donc vous
devez savoir de quoi je parle c'est quoi
les indic il y a le comment linge non la
machcartécé il y a le Témo voisin qui
entendent des hurlements alors qu'elles
étaient en train de fumer une cigarette
elles sont à une centaine de mètres
elles entendent vers 11h ou 23h 23h30
elles entendent des hurlements il y a eu
des vérifications de fête pour voir si
c'était techniquement possible et çatait
il y a les lunettes cassé de de Delphine
alors vous allez me dire qu'elle a pu
les casser avant tout fait en fait elle
P marcher dessus bien sûr mais enfin ça
tombe mal il y a la voiture qui est
garée dans le dans le bon sens il y a la
dispute juste avant
VO le propre fils du couple jubilard dit
aux gendarmes qu'il y ait une dispute
assez violente entre les deux époux ce
soir-là donc
voulez pu tout çait vous pensez que
cette femme serait sortie toute seule
23hur pour aller
prendre canard Mo vous savez dans dans
cette avis là Mo moi je ne pense pas des
affaires j'en ai vu beaucoup j'ai vu des
chosesussi très improbables et je peux
vous assurer que moi aussi VO vous êtes
bien plac pour sair éal on peut tout
imaginer par contre ce qui est concret
c'est que là nous n'avons rien de
concret là-dessus et même au niveau de
la voiture qui a été regardé 10 fois je
veux dire aujourd'hui on a rien et quand
je dis qu'il y avait des risques le
téléphone portable qui rebouge après
qu'il a donné l'alerte c'est quand les
gendarmes sont dans la maison il y a le
téléphone de
Delphine sur la borne de la du domicile
c'est pas rien quand même ça on est
d'accord mais mais mais mais mais has
vous n'avez rien pour dire que que c'est
lui qui l' fait en fait merci
aujourd'uiou merci à vous deux merci
cyine merci Michel merci à vous tous
d'avoir été avec N merci pour votre
témoignage tout de
suite
des